yoth monde c'est squeeze aujourd hui on
se retrouve sur tekken avec mon frère
pour jouer en mode combat celui d'un
coma érotique plus précisément c'est à
dire qu'on a fabriqué des persos plutôt
sexy comme vous pouvez le voir à l'écran
oui toi par exemple fameux poulpe ouvéa
loi j'ai une femme poulpe bon alors
évidemment je vais prendre une branlée
monumental par mon frère qui s'est
plutôt un peu mieux joué que moi bon
même si là on peut croire que non vous
allez voir qu'il suffit qu'ils
commencent et ne s'arrête plus exact on
regarde ça avec elle mais ce te faire
[ __ ] coucouche c'est le fameux rocher
me sucer la tentacule attend là avec le
vieux pêcheur qui fait qu'on est dans le
poisson voilà ça c'est le fric que je
suis pas dans taken as compris tu peux
passer ma chance de percer notre tiens
je te met des coups de tentacules t'as
vu non non non qu'elle soit 4 concentré
tu parles des meubles c'est excellent
jeu me fait [ __ ] alors je te dévoile
ce que ce monsieur des boîtes à hainaut
like it my brother a combattu des bois
d'arcy
comment ils veulent des fois les persos
et si on changeait de personnages ça me
semble bon alors c'est partir au combat
de gros mec russe enfin mon frère à geek
et bob voilà déjà ça soit directe mais
elle soit matin tous te plait je m'en
fous c'est bien mais mon gosse tartuffe
et une prise n'importe quoi c'est toi
qui l'a fait toi tu vraiment c'est qui
ce sont des menteurs c'est la ccima
profondeur abattage a reculé comme un
croisement
alors je te pète d'un seul bras à l'esat
en arabe et en persan t'apprend à bas le
panda mais florent il troubles et matic
le bol impulsive je n'ai pas pensé je
sais pas si elle a bon dos tu es morte
en mettant trop de gras sans toi détends
toi genau mec t'as la meuf avec lada et
qu'elle est trop fort attention bonjour
à toi je voulais faire mais tu as tu vas
enfin ce qu'ils avaient d'être ma super
nova en revanche tu t'es pris une belle
revanche
non non attendez stockés dans les heures
non je te fais plus de feu pourquoi
c'était une mise en scène ça s'appelle
le vin de merde mais arrête de faire
cette grosse [ __ ]
mais pourquoi mais je comprends voiture
a peut-être parce que j'ai des frères
squeeze rendent pas compte a même un
curieux importe quoi on casse les
couilles
aux adieux
bon bah voilà
à bientôt
oui